i don't feel like it's much of a stretch
to be like
because i know what it is to be reminded
of someone who's not you
at because
everywhere i go not everywhere i go but
once a day someone will come up to me
and go how's dave
almost every day
chappelle like people a lot of people
know and why are you taking that as
being reminded of somebody better than
you
well dave's way more
success dave's more talented like i
don't i i i i see where you're going
with that and i appreciate it dave's a
supernova do you know what i mean like i
don't and
somebody rock actually said one time
like you're not competitive with dave
because i there's no point it's not like
we're
it's a sprint and we're super close like
it's he did but here's what i found
fascinating about you the ability to
write and create
you know you know each one of us every
human being outside even outside the
business has a tone
or has a um
you know yeah yeah tone is a
vibration yeah yes and you seem to be
able to write to you know you you you
know i've had
probably you know 10 failed pilots
and the reason i had failed pilots you
know they would come and see me in a
club or they knew me this is in the 80s
and they'd go how we got to do abc wants
to do the next howie mandel show and and
nbc wants to do next and you play oh
and then they would go we're putting you
with a showrunner yeah and they always
put you with for those that don't know
the showrunner is king in this in this
town and and i get it because when
you're going to do a show
a television show the cheapest show is
in the millions yeah you know it's a
million dollars an episode for a half
hour of regular four days three and a
half right so it's a million dollars of
television so in those days they gave
you an initial order for 13. now it's
maybe down to 10. but
somebody had to say yes to 13 million
and because they saw you do stand up and
because they think you're a funny guy
that's a lot of money to put behind that
but the showrunner
is the creative person that can they
believe guarantee that they can come up
with not just one funny pilot script but
13 yeah and
100 right and potentially 100 and and
that's why
regardless of how excited they are about
you they always want to put you with
like the chuck lorries was right well
known in in you know he did the big bang
theory and two and a half men
and
and the guy who did ray romano show and
phil rose
yeah so those are the people so but they
always put me with somebody who i'm not
denying wasn't great right but it's got
to be the right fit but never never
picked up my vibe
never was even close to my vibe right
and i was always you know cow towing to
that well this is what the network you
want to cancel you know i i wasn't like
roseanne who was strong enough to
uh say fire people fire people and say
that i wouldn't say this i wouldn't do
it like that so i'm fascinated and this
is where i think the talent is
because i know
i know you don't talk about it but i
know some of the sketches that you're
responsible for and there's some of the
outstanding sketches the fact that you
have the ability to tune in to his vibe
and create
something that he could a
a platform that he could blast off from
almost means a little more to me i'm not
knocking dave
but the
i would argue that i that wasn't the
relationship the relationship wasn't
like come here kid i'm gonna like i was
a doorman
at a comedy club so i went to and i went
to um i would go visit new york see my
brother see all those guys and then i
got into nyu film school
and i was going to film school and then
i started working the door at a comedy
called the boston comedy club
in in the village in new york and that
was 91 92 dropped out in 92 because i
was working the door
at night and the film students are the
biggest [ __ ]
alive and uh they're just so pretentious
and whatever so it was like i can either
hang out with these pretentious
[ __ ] or down at that club is uh
an unknown dave chappelle an unknown
louis ck an unknown sarah silverman
unknown david tell unknown jon stewart
on all these people and i was like i
think they're unknown marc maron like i
think those guys are wanda sykes like
would she was a married to a man that
like
those i like them like that seems more
vital than these people so i'm working
the door to comedy club i start working
uh not even morning just pitching [ __ ]
to comics like hey made me say this
maybe say that which is
very aggravating like the first people
said dave actually says his first
instinct when i pitched a joke to him
was to like wince and then it was good
and he was like oh
so
uh
so and then that built that that grew
into
we wrote a couple bigger jokes together
and then we wrote half baked together
and then we did the tv show together but
i was never
uh
a
i like him do you know what i mean like
and i'm i'm very talented but i have to
kind of love the person but it's kind of
like larry david and jerry seinfeld yeah
but larry i don't know if i could do cr
i don't there's something about dave
and sketches like i wrote for all that
on nickelodeon i wrote like i wrote some
stuff in in
in the intervening years uh when i
wasn't writing with dave but we were
still friends and i love i'm a very good
uh
like sort of like scent dog like hound
dog if you give me the thing like i'll
[ __ ]
go and bring back but it's amazing that
the same person writing sketches and all
that is writing sketches on the
chappelle show right he's writing for
the daily show right well the funny
thing is
i was better at writing for i was
writing chappelle show sketches for all
that and it wasn't going so well oh you
got to know your audience no exactly
like i just would have funny ideas but
it just was like for the wrong
wrong uh crowd so
so i don't see that as like i was any
kind of svengali with anybody i just i
can
i you people have like a tone like you
said a tone or a vibration or a
frequency which is a word that me and
dave kept saying when we started working
on the show
and you just sort of like
you get this essence
and it it it
if you do it correctly if it's a dank
enough essence
you can it can influence every it can
influence the logo it can influence the
production design it can influence
cost it can everything right and so i'm
good at that because i think that
audience
always
is attracted to authenticity yes and you
know you need to change all the if you
have a tone you know it's like
you can have a nice shirt but if you
wear with the wrong pants it's not
really a nice shirt you don't have a
nice outfit and it's kind of like that
same thing
[Music]
you